on Shepherds Bush green and West London
groups of more than two people were
still gathering in defiance of the Prime
Minister's strict new rules on social
distancing others were sunbathing just a
day after police were forced to
intervene here to spell out in blunt
terms what's meant by the stay-at-home
policy those we spoke to didn't think
they were doing anything wrong as you
see we asked you think you just with my
best friend and distance between us
about two meters or do you think you're
safe enough socially yeah yeah yeah in
public spaces across the country numbers
have reduced and for the most part
people are maintaining a safe distance
from each other until no police here on
Shepherds Bush Green and elsewhere
around the country have only been able
to explain and try to persuade people to
move on but this new law will now give
them the power to actively disperse
gatherings and to find those who refuse
to obey the lockdown despite the new
powers police still intend to tread
softly unless they're left with no
choice we will only want to use
enforcement if we absolutely have to but
we won't hesitate if there are people
who are flagrantly breaching the law
hundreds of British Transport Police are
on duty at wheel hubs nationwide York
station like others seeing a vast
reduction and commuters on the London
Underground outside rush hour most
passengers are still able to keep their
distance from each other and everybody
make distance between each of them but
on the London Underground there are
still significant problems during the
morning and evening rush hours and
police are now actively trying to
dissuade those who don't need to travel
we've been out in the suburbs talking to
people as they begin their journey
and we've had some cases where we've
persuaded people not to travel and also
in others where we've not really been
satisfied with the reasons for their
journey making it clear that we don't
want to see them again tomorrow the
police nor the importance of trying to
keep the public onside this will be a
drawn-out process but they now have the
extra powers they need should further
restrictions be necessary mark white Sky
News